this is a production of Cornell
University
um now if I did this the wrong way you
might say I did because I listen to
frank Rossi when i said i was giving
this seminar and frank's it kind of you
know not a lot of data you know put a
few jokes in there so i'm following his
advice so if it goes awry don't blame me
blame him Oh basically what I was going
to do is really just give a good
overview of the types of data that go
into climate research in working with
Dave and a number of people here at
Allen you know that that always comes up
where are we getting this data from you
know the observed data the data from the
past the current data that we use and
then more importantly as we move on to
it the data we're going to use in the
future so that's kind of a little bit of
background about my slide and then just
kind of going over the contents really
hear that the middle part is going to be
kind of short changed but the first part
of the last part is where I'm going to
focus most of my effort focusing on the
first part in this kind of intriguing
bullet here Climategate they would know
the whole scandal of emails in the
research lab in East Anglia and things
like that yeah try to shed a little bit
of light on that and really that the
bottom line and all of that is no
climate data have been collected for a
number of years 100 years 100 years at
least but never with the intent of
monitoring climate change so it's
basically data set that's out there it's
been used for other purposes had its
roots pretty much in agriculture and
it's only now recently that we've been
using these data to to monitor climate
change and that has some implications to
it and hopefully I'll bring that out in
some of my call and then really in the
end what we have to boil down to is
trying to project these climate
parameters into the future 100 years in
the future how can we go about doing
that and more importantly how can we do
go about doing that at the scale that is
just right most of the models we operate
on are these big global climate models
that have kind of one observation for an
area about the size of New York but yeah
we're interested in can we will would be
able to grow grapes in the Finger Lake
in 2100 or will this crop do well in New
York and so forth and so on so there
it's a matter of getting the size just
right really the whole backbone of the
climate network observed climate network
in the United States is something that's
called the historical climatology and
I'm going to use the US as an example
but this is a good example for pretty
much anywhere else in the world where
there is an extensive set of observed
meteorological data going back on
hundred years so most of Europe same
thing in China and Russia really these
types of issues and things are things
that come up in all the connections for
the u.s. there are proper a thousand
stations in this network to cover the
size of the US the resolution of these
data is primarily daily so not hourly
David things like that connealy and
really it's measuring three things the
daily maximum temperature the daily
minimum temperature and how much
rainfall the daily precipitation that's
really the hundred year record are
really applies to these measurements
many stations almost all of them to have
50 year records some have more than 100
years records and like i said before
never intended to really track climate
change it kinda just to put this into
perspective you know the historical
climate network is pretty much the cream
of the cream of these patients if we
look at any old station there's about
today about six thousand eight thousand
summers in there depending on where we
are stations that actually record these
observations if I use a rain gauge it's
an example if I took every rain gauge
that was operational in the United
States today and put them rim to rim
okay you want to venture a guess how big
of an area that would cover me go ahead
tom no not run island they always been a
soccer star Neil is closer a tennis
court okay we take every rain gauge in
the US put a room to rim we got a tennis
court so that kind of gives you an idea
of what we're dealing with here to
measure climate change or anything
on a national scale there's this
distribution of these stations pretty
much have good coverage but across the
country kind of smarts and some of the
areas you would expect them to be sparse
but overall a pretty good coverage this
is what a typical states this is kind of
what a typical station looks like this
is the game farm road station and really
a few extra instruments here but the
main ones are this rain gauge here with
a windshield around it and to
temperature sensors we'll talk about
that a little bit more later the primary
sensor is this one right here which is
called the maximum temperature sensor
the one thing about the US historical
climate network is it citizen science in
action it's in citizen science forever
these things are pretty much in people's
backyards okay so this is an example of
the station well which one it is in the
historical time at network the rain
gauges out of the frame but here's the
human TS the network also expands to
some Airport station so here's the
temperature sensor at binghamton which
is part of this but for the most part
these are volunteer networks The Weather
Service is applying the instrumentation
but the volunteers supplying the
manpower there are some bad apples and
this is really the crux of climate game
so here's an example of an MMTS that's
in some bushes and right by a big a
small parking lot not the best exposure
for measuring temperature here's an even
worse exposure for measuring temperature
that's a burn barrel and there's a fair
number of these again a really bad
exposure here this is the temperature
sensor up there so I mean you don't need
to be a climatologist to figure out that
these are not good
um however these few bad apples I mean
these are just the bad examples that I
picked out here what I want to say is
they got spoiled a bunch so if we
actually go out and look at these
stations okay and it was kind of it's
kind of you know the sad part about it
is when these stations were selected to
be in the US climate network probably
about 30 years ago 20 years ago nobody
went out and looked at them they look at
the length of record they looked at the
amount of missing data they never looked
at the sites so that's why these bad
apples are are in the bunch but when we
look at this basically the blue line is
a temperature trend over the last 50 or
so years from the good stations the bath
stations the cream of the prompts the it
because the stations that are a nice
pristine environment the red line is all
of the stations so if we take all of the
station the bad apples and all and what
we can see is that really those few had
bad apples make some difference in the
exact numbers but overall if we're
looking at the trend we have the same
pretty much magnitude and powder to
trenton time okay so when these
scientists from east anglia were
criticized for taking some data out of
their analyses what they were actually
doing was separating out the bad apples
that occur not only here but across the
globe I could have cake examples of
stations like this from any country
again they are the mayor the exceptions
rather
the data are processed in a number of
different ways in their process to
remove non climatic things that creep in
so it's pretty much the easiest things
are things like quality control and
missing data and urbanization basically
here are very simple adjustment on the
raw data to adjust for populations
something like a growing city or
population is changing gets adjusted
that warming due to urbanization is
removed from the data and again quality
control is really my wall green sign
it's not 500 big ones so things like
that and I mean this is probably a
common error keeping in mind up until
very recently these things were keyed in
from paper forms the observer went out
to the station located a number sent in
his form or her form at the end of the
month and somebody digitized these so
it's very easy that you know 50.1 got
keyed in is 5501 the stations are
adjusted for relocations um this is the
current Ithaca station this is the
Ithaca station in 1930 that is the
temperature shelter you would know what
building that is Robert all the brief of
Roberts Hall was the official
observational science 1930s under other
stuff up here was really warm it was my
Academy disinterred the record highs in
Ithaca are in the 1930s why it's a black
roof on top
okay lot las get right here we're are
bowed at the same level so kind of if
you want a fact you know think of
climate change that way for Roberts
hauling a front rotor about even
actually back chair Ithaca was an
official weather service station there
was a weather bureau office in Roberts
hall and just as a this thing up here is
actually the signal flags they throw a
flag you know you see a hurricane flag
or something like that plane there used
to be one of those on the roof of Robert
Hall um the data are adjusted for a
change in instrumentation basically
prior to the mid-1980s the temperatures
were taken by a maximum minimum
thermometer liquid and glass enclosed in
the Stevens discrete in mid 1980s most
of the station's thought almost moved on
to an electric sensor here which is a
thermocouple inside the mnts so these
are the two basically for the last
hundred years these are the only two
types of instruments the day are also
adjusted for observation time these are
once a day observations of maximum
minimum temperature taken by volunteers
so I'm an early riser and for me it
might be easier to take my observation
in the morning before I come into work
so if I were doing that and this is my
example of a morning observation if I
was coming in and say I took my
observation at 7am thanks so if I took
my observation at 7am on this morning I
would be looking at the lowest
temperature of this 24-hour period and
it just so happened to occur right when
I took the observation okay so this
value is a little bit colder than that
though so that's my minute i reset my
thermometer can only go to the minimum
temperature I can't make it anymore
filter or any more warmer then I come
back the next day throughout this whole
period the temperature has risen okay so
when I take my observation here say what
was the minimum temperature in the last
24 hours
it was over here okay so when I take my
observations in the morning I tend to
count a particularly cold morning twice
okay if I'm the opposite rather do it
when I came home from work I have the
opposite problem I now take my
observation at the time of day and
whoops looks like mac and pc messed up
these for school silly lined up I take
my observation at the time of the
temperatures the warrants so if I came
and I look at this period of time this
would be my max not that and then if I
came the next day at 5pm I would be
counting that next once so the same type
of thing but but in the effort so the
morning observers can have a cold bias
the afternoon observers can have a warm
bites and this wouldn't be a problem if
observers were random but there has been
a systematic shift through time to take
morning observations so there's been an
artificial cooling in the climate record
due to that but really this adjustment
is pretty easy to figure out and it's a
pretty robust adjustment knowing what
the observation finals so let's look at
this this is some trends in the hcn but
basically how does what is the
difference as we add each of these
adjustments so the Green Line is just if
we fill in missing data and nothing
really there to write home about the red
line is the instrument adjustment so
this is when we shifted from a cop
region shelter to an MMTS mid-80s and as
you can see that that caused a very
slight warm bias to the record the
record warm our adjustment had to be
toward warm I set that backwards the
bias is actually cooling and this is the
adjustment
if we look at the change in observation
time again a systematic shift to morning
observations as a cooling so our
adjustment we have to add warming to the
record and there you can see the
magnitude of this is on the order of
degrees f unfortunately but about a
third of a degree the station moves
again the adjustment is towards warming
and the reason for this is through time
there's been a systematic shift in
having stations in the center of a city
and then moving them out to an airport
vacation so Baltimore might be a good
example where the station used to be in
the courthouse in the center of
Baltimore Nick got moved out to the
airport okay that in this case that's a
big enough move that it counts as two
stations but that gives you the general
flavor of these foods so there's no
there's a a cooling or actually the
implicit example is a good example of
that another systemic shift was from
rooftop locations to ground locations so
they're in the cooling in the record
that has to be adjusted
urbanization of course has the opposite
effect and here this population
adjustment is about a tenth of a degree
Fahrenheit so really the thing is the
biggest difference there is the
observation time at the station boots
which together are about a half hour
late I'm crisp I don't quite understand
if with a maximum minimum thermometer
either automatic or one that you can
read the minimum temperature doesn't
matter when the temperatures taken um so
what's this biasing I don't it does
because they're not electronic
thermometers like an ADA logger where
you know what everything is at every
hour every minute of the day so
basically the best analogy I can give to
the liquid and glass thermometers and
they've continued that in the electronic
thermometer it's like a fever
thermometer so you know you take your
temperature with a fever thermometer if
it's 103 it's you know you pull it out
of your mouth it's 103 and it's days of
103 until you shake it down ok so these
thermometers work exactly the same way
it records the highest temperature that
has been recorded since you have
resetting nothing in between does that
make sense
right and the whole reason there is is
primarily the federal government is
broke and devoid on technology or
they're working on antiquated technology
but the other reason to is you have this
big long record you know 100-year record
of doing it one way the current
technology of electronic kilometres when
the observer goes out the game farm road
there is a readout that basically says
what was the highest temperature that
was recorded in the last 24 hours and
what was coolest and that's it ok there
have been moves and we'll see to get
away from that in that today this keep
in mind this is my I forget what it was
times fast um the other thing is the
u.s. temperature record from
measurements like this very much mirrors
the National of the global record so if
we see the u.s. record kind of a flat
period in through the 40s excuse me
arise from the 1900s to about the 1940s
a decrease to about the 1970s increase
we see the same type of thing I have a
different scale here but here's my rise
in the nineteen hundreds to about 1940 I
kind of decrease or flat paraded through
the 70s and my rise really the US record
is a good match to the global record
all right the president finally last
five years or so the Noah said hey we
need to do something to really monitor
climate change we need a network that
really doesn't and they've instituted
what is called is the climatological
reference network this is about 100
stations across the u.s. given by the
yellow dots one up here in canada the
layout of these dots was done very site
typically we were involved in some of
the work to say what is the minimum
stations we can put out in the u.s. to
get a good measure of what the
temperature trend has been ok so a lot
of actually the siting of these stations
spacing between these stations is
scientifically based a CRN station looks
like that those are the two in New York
there's one out at the animal science
facility in Harford and there's one down
at Millbrook ok actually the the climate
Center was involved in citing these
stations and it was a real bear
particularly in the Northeast because
one of the requirements of these
stations and there was a whole review
process is that the area around the
station could not be expected to change
for 50 years so we wanted to have Game
Farm Road be one of these stations but
when we went you know one of the review
processes was look at okay what is
Cornell's plans for expansion that's the
way they planned on expanding so that
automatically Nick's so if you're able
to do that up in Harford and this was
really hard in the Northeast because
number one it couldn't be upon private
land it always have to be on publicly so
we had actually a nice facility out
anybody by the veg Harvick George Jr I
thought that would be a great location
for a site but George mirrors on private
land is publicly I mean it's it's
privately held land so that that got
makes so really hard especially in the
Northeast society
stations but anyway rain gauge in their
electronic sensors there there's
actually three redundant sensors all
looking at the same thing actually
within this measuring solar radiation
measuring wind there are some things to
see if things are out of whack between
the sensor so they really hit this
upright really monitor climbing into the
future and this is like five minute 80
Chris so now we don't have this problem
um and really increasingly a lot of
Union so locally they try to avoid like
a party sites um the criteria for citing
these yes they did basically they think
you know a lot of argument of where you
put something along the coast but as as
long as the coast reflected that trend
in the temperature or needed to you know
those stations were looked at and how
much did that affect the u.s. trend
there was inciting there but most of
them are actually been away from large
bodies of water every criteria um you
know increasingly now our observations
globally us are coming from remotely
sense but so we have a nice satellite
record going back the end of the 70s and
really what I'm trying to show here is
the blue is surface observations and a
number of different satellite platforms
and here are the trends if you can make
them out are a little bit different the
slope is different but yet the same type
of an increase and just because there's
satellites these same types of problems
that creep into station data also creep
in the satellite the satellite orbits
degrade through time and that has to be
adjusted you know changes in atmospheric
moisture might affect the satellite
records it's just because it's coming
from a satellite doesn't mean it's
devoid of these types of things that go
on into service and increasing weight
for for rainfall radar is becoming a
also a lot of our information and this
is really kind of my transition and
going from global circulation models
observations a lot of our observations
is we use a data set that's called the
reanalysis in the best way to describe a
reanalysis as it takes all kinds
basically data from any number of
platforms radio songs weather balloons
aircraft surface observations satellite
how clouds are moving to get an idea of
the wind and these are the data that go
into initializing weather forecast
models right so if i have a gridded
model to predict tomorrow's weather i
need to give it its initial conditions
and these are the types of data that go
into that okay so what has been done is
going back 30 or even in some cases 50
years to take the observations that go
into initializing these forecasts put
that through a standardized routine so
the routine doesn't change your time
okay and then come up with a gridded
data set that blends all of these
platforms together so it's giving me
things like precipitation it's giving me
things like surface temperature but it's
also giving me things like wind speed
and pressures and Heights and where the
highs and lows are okay much like a
global circulation model does so this
reanalysis data set sort of is going to
order does provide a benchmark to global
circulation models and I'll show that in
some of my later slides all right so the
future so really what is a climate model
getting to the to the title of my talk
you know if I can't get the weather
right tomorrow how do i get the climate
right you know hundred years so really
an upside a model you have to take this
whole big climate system the atmosphere
the Sun the volcanoes the oceans the ice
the greenhouse gases clouds you know the
agriculture in the land surface and
basically turn that into a model so even
though that's a nice picture oops
my aunt there comes no basically I'm
taking all of that in turning it into a
lot of cute so basically that is the
crux of the climate model or not we're
not going to go through a couple
equations but
that
all right what's it why do I bother
wings because I think again it's just an
analogy I was trying to think I think
anybody can say if I turn on the lava
lamp what's going to happen to the love
let's go to rise in the lane okay so
that's the basic physics of what's going
on i'm heating the lava from from the
bottom in its price okay but if i asked
a different question you know how big is
each blob lava as it rises you know or
predict you know when this guy rises the
next one rises how big is it's going to
be nobody's going to know that's more
like the weather or an example i usually
do i don't have it if i drop the piece
of paper okay master whoa if i ask you
to model what was going to happen to the
paper if I let go Udall say it's going
to fall to the floor right that's cool
that's the climb okay if I ask you where
it was going to land every time I drop
it it's going to land someplace
difference and that's just the the chaos
and then it's gonna be somewhere it's
different and nobody's media that's the
web so again here in the climate by
example this yes we're looking at if we
add greenhouse gases what is the overall
trend gonna do but really what we don't
expect the models again are these
interannual variations the model doesn't
know you know the model might replicate
El Nino but the models has no idea in
what year in El Nino is going to occur
so maybe in a hundred years the model
will get a right and they'll be an El
Nino you know every seven years or at
the historical rate of El Ninos but if
it's going to it's not going to occur
you know you can't look at the models
they owe the model is predicting in El
Nino in 2060 you can't expect that to
happen so you won't see where I'm trying
to get at so we're getting the overall
trend but the timing of these types of
swivels is not right or we can't expect
it to be a good example of that is the
last several years over the last 10
years we've actually if you look at a
trend in cooling or flat people say all
climate change
well done that that cooling part is
we're in one of these ballots and I
mentioned it will come out so the model
is trying to get the cultural trend the
gross aspects of things it can to be
expected to get every way okay models
are gritted basically the whole globe is
divided into a number of grid boxes kind
of on you know resolution changes with
time pretty much state-of-the-art now
it's maybe a hundred kilometers on the
side of degree by a degree maybe ism is
it this size global circulation model
grid boxes go up into the atmosphere
grid boxes go down into the ocean but
the idea is no each of these grid boxes
is a node in the model so there's one
value for each of these script boxes one
value temperature one value for
elevation
all of the models and there are a number
of different climate models out there
any number of climate groups has the
role model but yet all of these models
share pretty much a common set of four
physical equations okay they need to
conserve momentum they need to serve us
in a special case momentum in the
vertical through the hydrostatic
equation they need to conserve mass they
need to conserve energy and the equation
of state needs to apply to get so at the
crux of all these models this is it
these are you know these are the four
equations but really where the art comes
in to state-of-the-art climate model is
through how things are parametrized how
do we take care of things that occur at
grits at scale that is smaller than the
grid scale of the model so here a good
example maybe not a good example I can
get a good picture here this is clouds
okay now where clouds really matters at
the scale of the individual drops if I
look at a cloud or you know the acidic
on my cloud physics class whether a
cloud is going to reflect solar
radiation or allow solar radiation pass
through or absorb long wave radiation
really depends on what are the sizes of
the drugs in the sizes of the drops are
like nanometers okay where the small
scale here and basically what is the
density of those drops so these are
things that are on many orders of
magnitude smaller scale that the model
is able to to take into account keep in
mind we have about a degree by a degree
box and we have to say it's cloudy or
it's not side okay so those types of
things need to be parameterised the
model and again kind of simple things if
the relative humidity in the model over
the grid box reaches a certain level
it's cloudy but this cloud has this
albedo in it based on that so there are
a number of ways to do it and that's how
one model may differ from another so
that's why my answer might have to be
different than somebody else's so we
have a spread of solution
future mainly due to how these are
records and again there's been a whole
evolution through time not only this
these fa RSA RTR are the IPCC reports so
that's the first assessment report the
second the Ford finally I guess they
needed to do something because the
fourth and the fifth were both can be
hard but anyway you can see the size of
the grid boxes are going from about
about 500 kilometers on the side in the
first assessment report to about 100
kilometers on the side now the way
things are parameterised in the models
has changed dramatically you know in the
70s there were no clouds if there was
enough water in the atmosphere rained
out and that was it no clouds you know
even here in the 70s there was the ocean
there was just a lot of water and the
water was allowed to evaporate but there
was no current there was no deep
circulation in the ocean all the ocean
was plus a source of water vapor for
campus here and then finally as we get
into the recent period of time and we
got a really sophisticated model we have
an ocean with a circulation deep
circulation surface circulation
atmospheric chemistry is starting to be
modelled the vegetation that the surface
starts to interacting is dynamic not
just static through time so a whole
evolution in how these models have come
about and primarily the thing that's
that's going on here is an increase in
computing power really right on through
this the models and pushing the
available computer power all right so
kind of going back through how well my
models are doing if you remember the
observations and these are the global
observations we have this period of time
from 1902 1924 the temperature rises
cooling in through the 40s through the
70s and the rise again switch
kind of zigzag pattern let's see what
happens when we try to model with so one
of the nice things about a climate model
is we can play games with the climate
model we can we can in some ways play
God we can add greenhouse gases we can
take away greenhouse gases we can make
volcanoes erupted we can not make
volcanoes erupted we can make the Sun
brighter we can make the Sun theorem we
can do all of these things and see how
that impacts what the op of the Ottomans
so here is an example again of my zigzag
of temperature and a climate model that
is run with the only change through this
period of time is the change in the
greenhouse gases so the greenhouse gases
in the model are changed according to
what has been observed and as we can see
this red line is the model it really
doesn't match very well with the
observed in through here you know the
trend is about right there all set mrs.
is cooling totally and not really this
right not a big mansion be the same
thing in this case keep the greenhouse
gases constant and the only thing change
in the model is the change in the
natural forces and here basically
volcanic eruptions and changes in the
solar intensity and if we look at that
well if you notice the model here um
again in the red kind of matches a
little bit better here starts to match a
little bit better here and then we have
this rise finally we put it all together
okay have the observations in black and
kind of my general trends in
whoo the model in red and we see that
the model at least they might in my view
matches the observations fairly well
we're able to capture this warming in
the early part of the record there
probably isn't it has nothing to do with
very little to do with greenhouse gases
but it has everything to do with the Sun
being brighter and there being a lack of
volcanic eruptions we get this cooling
fairly well into here fifties what's
going on there sulfate aerosols okay
burning dirty coal acid rain okay
basically the air aerosols that we emit
when we burn coal are reflected so they
reduce the amount of incoming solar
radiation and actually on this global
scale we have a cooling and then as we
get into the 70s this is the large
increase in greenhouse gases very little
to do with natural variations in this
period of time and also at a time of
moving cleaning of the clothes so theta
results of becoming less and less and
less in most parts of the world not all
part so again my example here of a
climate of climate model doing a pretty
good job of matching the observations
Billy throughout this whole hundred plus
year period of time
and then finally how do we get these big
large scale brit boxes to come down to
the local level how do we say okay this
box here that's the size of New Yorker
almost the size of New York that has one
temperature value one everything how do
we start to make some inferences on how
climate change will impact set the wine
industry perhaps water resources in the
New York City Watership things that
happen on a small scale we don't care
about what's going on globally or even
New York sighs we need to bring these
data down to down to a different level
and just as an example of what I mean
this is the United States and this is
the elevation of the United States is
seen by climate model so you do see the
Rocky Mountains here and kind of the
white but they're no more than a little
pump a little bump on the map but if we
go down to the scale we really eat we
want the mountains to look like that
that's the thing that's driving the
snowpack in the West in water resources
in West not this little pump in that so
these types of features start to become
very very important when we want to look
at ulta scaling pets or even reaching
scale attacks
so the way we get from one to another is
through a process that's called
downscale I'm really here it's an idea
of resolving the mismatch of the scales
show some examples it can be done
statistically or it could be done
dynamically so basically using a finer
scale model to do the downscale both of
these have their origins in weather
prediction in the current state of the
art is one is no better than the other
they both have their pros and cons in
the end either one of these is
acceptable we've been doing a lot of
work recently in the climate project
that Dave and Jonathan have been
involved with him and us over in
bradfield really looking at statistical
downscaling but we've been doing some
dynamical downscaling to for things like
lake effect snow that kind of lends
itself to that application just to give
you an idea of how this works in weather
forecasting ok this is the results for
the last week of the EAS weather
forecasting and a bunch of these are
students but basically what i wanted to
show is the best forecast here is
basically through a statistical
downscaling okay so it's a totally
statistical forecasts this has no no
person is involved ok it comes right off
the computer and that's actually doing
quite well it's reading me ok um and
that's a consensus so this is a number
of these different statistical
approaches here's a particular
statistical approach again it's doing
fairly well brian is our computer guru
and he runs the dynamical model
basically takes the forecast right from
the model again the Model T so this idea
of downscaling from a model to the game
farm road weather station it's we see it
in action in weather forecasts and my
argument here is either I'm doing pretty
poorly or it does it is doing pretty
well in this case for this mess
total square by sake anybody it was your
you load ah one of the one of the
undergrads so Haley um you know so we
look at statistical downscaling first
really the biggest Pro is it's
computationally and expensive it's easy
to do or relatively easy we can tailor
it to specific variables we can look at
some exotic things things that aren't
even in the climate models storm surges
air quality perhaps um can be made
site-specific but the downsides is the
biggest downside perhaps is it's not
describing the physical process we're
making a big leap of faith that whatever
we're basing our statistics on isn't
changing in the future right so we're
saying okay whatever the relationship
we're looking at today are basing our
bottle on today is going to hold in the
future and that may or may not be a good
assumption the simplest way to do this
is just to say okay I use this
Providence basically if I want to look
at Providence and you'll precip and I
look at the GCM grid that accomplices
Providence and I strike a regression and
it's not a one-to-one relationship if it
were perfect but it somewheres off of
the 11 line and I can use that as my
density not very not very don't want to
say too much about that it's still a way
to do looking in some of the more common
ways that are doing this in the New York
assessment again that Dave and Jonathan
and some others in the room have been
involved with they use what's called the
Delta men and basically here we have an
observed distribution of temperature in
this case our observed period is from 70
to 2000 and we have what the model says
is the observed distribution
temperature for that particular point in
the same period of time and they don't
match up and then we have what the model
is saying the temperature is at some
point time in the future and the Delta
becomes the model present minus the
model future so this blue area there and
then that Delta is applied back to the
data so in other words here are my daily
observations from say of temperature
from save Rochester from 1970 into each
day all I do is add miss Delta so if
this Delta were five degrees each
observation here gets inflated by five
degrees again a fairly simple method of
doing it the biggest drawback in my mind
is the variability of the climate never
changes if it was cold on this day
relatively cold on this day in 1970 it's
going to be relatively close on that day
and in the future models just five
degrees warmer so the same progression
of temperature changes States it just
gets translated up working on some more
sophisticated methods actually look at
the whole distribution of temperature it
allows Delta to change nut defines Delta
not just at the median for the average
but across the whole distribution so
this would be my example here of perhaps
in the green and observed here we have a
cumulative distribution function of
percentage of observations you're
agreeing and how does the Delta change
at each of these nodes and maybe the
model is cooler at the very low end and
maybe it's higher at the very high end
and maybe
a large difference in the middle so each
of these are taking account and
therefore we can start to adjust gains
differently depending on how hot they
are gonna skip the next one another way
to do this is to look at a greater sweep
of predictors to use all this
information that the climate models give
us things like you know what is the 500
millibar height think of a weather map
how what are the winds doing a long so
use all this whole you know if you think
of I asked you know if I told you from
the model it was going to be cloudy
today and there was going to be a trough
over New York you know would you say
even basic weather would you say it's
gonna be a hot day or warmed in let's
try that again a hot day or a cold day a
cool day right a trough is generally
cool clouds we don't have any Sun so
that type of broad scale information
trying to get some information so we're
going to go here's an example of
downscaling using this for snow pack so
this is some work that we've done where
lots of lines you're probably not the
best graph to show on the screen the
black line is the historical snow depth
at Juan Aquino ranger station in the
other islands the blue line is basically
a climate model that we have downscaled
to that particular location so i would
argue that in my blue line we're doing
pretty good in getting the maximum
average snow depth is over a period of
time so in any average year you would
expect there to be at least 20 inches of
snow on the ground
pretty much getting the timing fairly
good the beginning in the end we're
losing our snowpack at least the similar
radar kinds off by a few by about a week
or two but we basically replicate this
fairly well in the downscaled the purple
the mustard in the red are the model run
on this station through into the future
so we've downscaled the data from the
GCM for the 20s the 50s and the eight
you see in the 20s the purple line we
reduce our snowpack a little bit not
much and kind of short nor snow season
there it's really not until the 50s the
80s that we really see dramatic
increases in the snow depth of this
nation based on this downscaling
basically going from on average 20
inches to on average about four inches
of snow at this adirondacks location
also notice not too much change in
what's going on at the beginning of the
season when we start with chameleon snow
but a dramatic change at the end of the
season for when we lose the snowpack
basically from mid mid may actually
early April and when the snow packed
into town so again a technique that can
be used for down skill
dynamical downscaling we're using
basically a model and model so it's
keeping the physics but it's very
computationally expensive as an example
I wanted to focus in on the u.s. what i
would do is have a small area just over
the u.s. globe kind of cut it out like a
patchwork quilt and basically the world
is going to end at these boundaries but
at each of the boundaries what's going
to be fed in our conditions from the
global circulation model so those global
grids basically are feeding what's going
on in this in this inner model and in
this inner model we can start to get the
resolution down to the things that might
resolve the Adirondacks and the lakes
and things along
example kind of is showing a number of
different approaches this is obviously
the Northeast these are data out of the
Northeast climate impacts assessment by
paola al and the NL is Dave wolf then I
was involved with that a number of other
public Cornell so this is a report that
preceded the climate report and we're
looking at precipitation here I believe
in this graphic and it in panel II these
are the stations and basically the Blues
are showing different levels of
precipitation on the scale H on the
other hand r is the precipitation from a
global circulation models that's why we
have these big patches each of these
boxes is one of the grit the f is if we
down scale is with a dynamic alarm so
feed this information into a finer scale
model you can get an idea of what the
grid size is from these boxes and you
can see we start to pick up more of the
detail you can see the Adirondacks and
their effect toward higher precipitation
you can see some of that down in the
Catskills as well and see some of the
mountains or graphic precipitation
coming out and then finally in this
panel here this is a statistically
downscale simulation of the same data
all of these are showing the same thing
stations global model dynamically
downscale statistically downscaled and
here this is down scales you about an
eighth of a degree resolution better
than this again
Ron Dax Catskills actually our highest
bring Bowl in New York is right around
here in the New York City Water [ __ ]
that we've done very nicely up and down
the mountain and I think I will open it
up for some questions here in the last
slide that you have so mg looks like
Connecticut gets a lot more rain but but
it doesn't you know in the large model
it page and then the other one enough so
why you know it seems like it's fairly
consistent with New York but all of a
sudden Connecticut let not and in New
Jersey you know and so that's the model
one goes again aspect of the model
basically probably some coastal
influences there if you actually look if
we actually look at the observations is
for as scarce as they are you know
basically you have this large air
Connecticut in the observation like most
of New York except except the high peaks
of the Adirondacks so in this case the
statistical method does make a little
bit more sense that way rather than this
keeping in mind up cheating a little bit
there because these observations are
driving the statistics they're not
driving the dynamical model and again an
example of this being used in real time
if you watch again going going from
climb into whether if you watch any of
the local weather you know whether casts
on TV where they kind of have their own
they basically are running their own
mini model especially now that it's
getting to you lake effect season you
know a big national forecast model
that's not going to get the lake effect
but these smaller models that can
resolve the lake resolve temperatures of
weight
we'll get that that's what's being used
on the small scale by the TV
meteorologists and actually the weather
service offices around the door so that
that type of information is there in
none of the global circulation models is
are the Great Lakes included I take that
back one or two so if we're looking at
something like Great Lakes that is just
something that is falling through the
cracks in these models and then even as
we get out of the smaller scale if we're
looking at things like what might be
going on with finger lights it's in most
of the finest scale models there you
know the Finger Lakes themselves are one
grid box so it's really tough even there
to look at that type of effect so we
really have a scale effect and go here
if we wanted to look at what's going to
be going on right in the lakes we have
to basically take the models that are
out there and actually increase their
resolution to get the lakes because the
lakes are just just just too small to be
resolved if they were a little bit
bigger they would be nicely in there but
their current size doesn't match up with
greeting in this box
Prescott yeah not sure how to ask this
actually but if go backwards in this in
this process you're talking about this
amazing increase in computing power
needs to do the global climate models
yet most people okay that's interesting
but I want to know what with a hundred
percent certainty what the weather is
going to be a week from today because
I've got a wedding to go to with it
right so is the computing power that
we're getting for the global climate
model filtering down to these more vocal
and shorter term situations it is to a
certain degree but I mean the bad news
is you're never going to get a hundred
percent accuracy because it's just the
chaos in the system the way you can have
as much computing power as you want but
the solutions to the equations that you
need to solve and in the real world part
in some cases you know they have
multiple solutions or do you have you
know the idea of a butterfly flapping
its wings and you go off in another
direction you're never going to have the
observations at a fine enough density to
resolve all of that to get it so you get
down to a level it's not so much the
computing power but the opposite know
you need to have the observations to you
know garbage in garbage out if you don't
have the observations at the scale that
things are happening you're not going to
be able to initialize the model with
those scales and even there the
equations can go awry with them with a
small to be where what is done both in
the weather scale and also the climate
scale is using what are called ensembles
so in other words I can and that's where
the computing power comes in I can take
my initialization of the model and tweak
it a little bit say I'm not exactly sure
what the state of the atmosphere
like right now so I'm going to say it
could look like this it could look like
that it could look like something else
and in each of those cases i'm going to
use that as an initial condition to my
model and then as I model it into the
future the idea is if you know the
initial state makes a big difference the
models are going to diverge and then i
can say chris flip a coin for your
wedding but if the if the if the
divergence you know if the models are
close together that gives you some
increase in certainty in your forecast
so I mean a lot I see Marty in the back
a lot of times when when when we do the
turf call you know i'll say i don't have
any confidence in what's going to happen
a week from now and then some weeks i
say yeah it looks pretty good it's going
to be hot it's going to try and cut up
what we're looking at there is no are
these ensembles going off in different
directions or are they all converging on
the same solution do the same thing with
the climate model and there you can not
so much tweak the initial conditions but
one what's done there is really the
thing that's driving the differences
there are how the Magos are
parameterised sorts now it's going to
make a big difference and is this guy
doing the clouds better than somebody
else so an ensemble of climate models
tends to be basically just different
models or slightly different models to
see how that progresses albums so you
know you never see you're never going to
see in 2100 that this is what the
temperature is going to be it's going to
be a range of temperatures to give me
respect to the duration tire latitude
the moms taken to considering albedo
changes um yes and though I guess I'll
ask you a question which models are we
talking about we took us out of there
have some closures at the global scale
yes and these dynamical models yes so if
you know in a dynamic model it's you
know even if we're at a small one
kilometer two kilometer great if it's
knowing more yes I mean that is clearly
one of the main things that will be
driving those models is what is the
albedo and that will be related to the
snowpack when we get into a statistical
model you know there is no there isn't
that getting take there in that case
it's basically at the large scale this
is what it's predicting and albedo is
you know part of that and it goes
through there's that answered the
question normal essa with respect to you
know discussions about that for station
on large global scale apparently albedo
consideration shirt on for app right and
that's I mean yes that's clearly
something that's that's used in the
models i mean i should we do in my
climate change last memory of paper
where they have a far estate a large
part of canada and the ideas that well
that should draw down
good thing for climate change but in the
end what it does is you're taking you
know they're doing this on the prairies
that are normally snow covered in the
winter so what you're doing is taking
with snow cover in putting coniferous
bars which has is absorbing a lot of
radiation so basically the radiation
effect absorbing that radiation equals
the same amount of warming that you get
you know by removing agreement so it's a
balance at the end due to that you know
that is one of the neat things about the
model so you can you can do those
exercises and those experiences clearly
when the models are run for these big
IPCC reports the runs take years to run
so the runs for the current the next
IPCC report are actually being ginned up
now a lot of the runs for these ice the
next round of IPCC reports will be done
at in not the entire flow but in a large
partial globe at a very fine resolution
will almost be like not dynamically
downscaling but actually running the
global models that select locations at a
very very fine scale the USB
so it's going to be a very different you
know as the models increase will see a
very different flavor to the kind of
IPCC reports that will come out in the
future it'll be much more global or
regional level you showed us why you
much better predictions climate
but down the scale as you describe do
you reduce a lot of points in that
manner so that the predictions you make
even for let's say that vs syracuse
become almost the same kind of noises
your weather forecasting
yes and no i mean what i want to say is
where it doesn't become the noise is if
you're representing a key process if
you're dying if you're dynamically
downscaling okay and let's use the lakes
as an example so let's say I care about
like how lake effect snow is going to
change or even in a forecast I care
about whether it was going to be like
the next know the fact that I'm putting
those lakes in there and allowing you
know physically modeling that process
I'm getting a lot of signal there if
we're going if we're taking the lakes
out and just saying okay how does the
temperature going to vary between maybe
not not a connoisseur cuse kids can
binghamton so to speak so they're really
it's just noise there's not a big
driving physical mechanism that would
make that change like with being Lincoln
thing my answer is going to be yes that
makes sense this is a real local
application question okay nervously I
think a journal good its information on
I believe there for DES come from
private forecasting company in state
college pennsylvania I don't know they
don't get it from us we you a long time
ago we used to i mean same type of thing
when i was at Rutgers many moons ago
meteorology department their new podcast
from local paper but it's the media
markets have gotten more global and
national and big companies it's all
going for these companies there is no
only thing that might come that does
come in a journal
confirmations that's unfortunate you
want a good for call the Cornell weather
phone where do you great what's a number
guess I'm embarrassed to say I don't
know off the time that's what some of
the new portal 2 yeah it's on the you
portraiture yeah somewhat on the Cornell
site all right I think you go to push
another question from Geneva go ahead
yeah I've heard cases where there's
suggestions that the night temperatures
will warm more than day temperatures in
the future how can you talk about about
that is it that always going to be the
case or what what's the basis of that um
that is definitely true in the
observations any of the models do show a
warming of of nighttime temperatures
relative to daytime temperatures um you
know it's not what it is not is the fact
that we're always radiating energy so
it's not the fact that go at nighttime
we're not getting any sunlight so we're
just radiating energy really there it is
a combination most of the the change in
nighttime temperature I believe has to
do actually with more land use change
and things like that where urbanization
and things along those lines even just
buildings and things like that have a
higher heat capacity so the heat is
being stored more at the day and then
being given off at night
that answered question Ella thanks so
tomorrow's election I've heard quite a
few Republican politicians the last
couple weeks saying that this whole
thing is just a liberal hopes to you
know get more votes or do you you think
the modeling will ever reach a level or
there there is some number of data
points or some margin error that we will
get to that will convince skeptics this
is really happening and I'm not saying
that oncologist the reason that I'm
saying that is they'll always be
uncertain I mean they're bowie's is it
and I think it's not an issue of whether
the science is correct or accurate or
not in mind is in my opinion it's an
issue of what do we have to do to
correct problem and the solution to the
problem is not peeling require drastic
changes in the way we do business and
operate society and things like that and
that's the thing that in my mind drives
the politics in the sides of things
you know where it becomes tough is you
know it is hard to say if you know if
I'm along the coast and I'm New York
City and I'm pretty darn you know
they're you know sea level rise got the
error bars there are getting smaller and
smaller and smaller you have a big
problem there's a lot of money I need to
solve that problem i'm here at upstate
New York off McNeil in Minnesota maybe a
few degrees of warming you know there's
opportunities so it's going to be
winners and losers so you have that that
part of thing too but if we're looking
collectively as globe clearly the
problem is there the solution to the
problem of global warming is in my mind
also the solution to a lot of the other
worlds problems and you know that whole
thing should be packaged together
perhaps we should end it there let's
thank our you again this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu